but there's another big problem in this
world today that contributes to this
nightmare and that is
fake news my friends i must show you the
fakest
of fake news i'm going to explain to you
something i've probably explained a lot
why break it down
why it is people in this country have no
idea what's going on and why their
brains are broken
boom so a good example actually let me
give the full context first
daily mail says quote let's go donald
trump
furiously orders aids to provide proof
to fox news's chris wallace
that joe biden wants to defund the
police and his staff can't provide any
first and foremost they framed the story
as though
it is not true let me just tell you
trump was right
joe biden does based on the common
understanding of what defund means
joe biden does want to defund the police
by his own admission his own words yes
absolutely we'll get to that
but what you need to understand about
why this story is so
annoying is when adam talks about
he's trying to convince people on
facebook or not even how to convince
people just explaining people like yo
you know uh here's here's a story that's
really important about why you know i
want to vote for trump yeah and then you
get a bunch of people saying like i
don't believe you
you know well how dare you
you vote for someone that is a bigot and
was like
that has nothing to do with what i just
like presented you like look at what i
just said
read the article that i i'm presenting
and you're just
you're coming at me with something
different well here's here's the best
example
earlier today you posted something about
joe biden will get back in bed with
china
right yeah and then someone was like
you're only saying that because trump
just said it's not true blah blah blah
and the difficult thing is you can pull
up 50 billion articles
that will make it seem like joe biden is
all about america but when you
actually dig in and look at the framing
you realize
it's just lazy journalism yeah and then
and then they they actually
some of them have messaged me privately
here's all this here's all the articles
that i was talking to about yup
and i read them all eighty percent of
them
trump allegedly did this trump allegedly
did this trump allegedly did this and
i'm like oh
i'm sick of this allegedly stuff it's
like give me the exact stuff because
everything i'm reading
i look into and it didn't actually
happen so it's them
saying whatever whatever we'll come back
to this go ahead but i want to make sure
everybody who's watching this gets an
understanding of how the media is broken
i bring you now to the daily mail you
see i read you this headline
trump furiously says you know i want
proof but he can't provide any oh no
trump oh oh no look at this trump claims
joe biden wants to defund police in
upcoming fox news interview
now we have this one from the hill fox
host chris wallace
chris wallace fact checks trump claim
biden wants to defund the police now
they're all a bit more neutral on this
but the reality is joe biden
absolutely does and i have for you the
interview where he literally says
yes let me see if well let's let's play
it hopefully the sound works
uh surplus military equipment for law
enforcement
they don't need that the last thing you
need is an up armored humvee coming into
a neighborhood it's like the military
invading
they don't know anybody they become the
enemy they're supposed to protecting
these people
so my generic point is do we agree that
we can redirect some of the funding
yes absolutely one of the things that
okay boom from now this yes absolutely
cut police funds they've become the
enemy first let me call out the trump
war room
he didn't say cut funding to the police
he said
redirect some of the funding and joe
biden said yes absolutely
now i bring you to the the new york post
story
in this interview chris wallace is like
he's talking to joe he's talking to
donald trump
and trump says well look joe biden wants
to defund the police and wallace goes
no sir he does not and trump's like yes
he does he just did this
this pact with bernie sanders let's go
and he calls his aides and his aides
can't find anything specifically
in the uh the this document with bernie
that says defund but it does talk about
like reallocation
more importantly however the new york
post does bring up this at the bottom
they say the bernie sanders unity agenda
does not use the term defund
but calls for policies that will
reorient our public safety approach
toward prevention
and away from over policing biden orally
committed last week to steering funds
away from the police
an interviewer asked the former vice
president but do we agree that we can
redirect some of the police funding
yes absolutely now i know right away
chris wallace is probably saying
while redirecting funds does not mean
defund or abolish and i'm sure
all of the lefties are going to be like
no you see biden someone tweeted this to
me
biden was talking about moving funding
from like one department to another no
he literally said redirect police
funding
okay you want to make you want to make
an assumption about what it means feel
free to do so i'm not going to do that
i'm going to show you
what they literally mean according to
the brookings brookings institute
defund the police means reallocating or
redirecting funding away from the police
department to other government agencies
funded by the local municipality that's
it
boom it's that simple it's that simple
so now you have all these people running
around you see stories like this ap
joe biden did not call for defunding the
police
hold on a minute if the definition that
they gave
okay in numerous instances because look
i'm i'm choosing these select sources
right right
there's 50 billion sources that say
defund means literally defund check this
one out
yes we mean literally abolish the police
that's helpful
okay man so i'll tell you what if joe
biden doesn't know what he's talking
about
you do not have the right to claim you
can read his mind and knew what he
really meant
what they're doing in the media is
they're using whatever definition
is is uh you know going to get them the
most
points yep so when when they first said
defund the police
and it shocked the minds of america when
they were like whoa defund the police
almost like i believe something like 80
or so say no to this
we do they don't want to see a reduction
in police funding but a lot of people
thought it meant
remove all funding from police yeah all
of a sudden we heard a split
a bunch of people said no no no it just
means like like demilitarize
like these these you know like like joe
biden was saying they got they got big
tanks
i don't need that become the enemy yes
he's taking the democratic party's
approach that
the police department should have a
little bit less funding because they got
too much big
big you know apcs and weapons and stuff
that is literally
one of the definitions of defund the
police yep according to the other
definitions it means literally abolish
but based on what joe biden said it does
fit what they're what they're claiming
and now the ap says this during claim
during an interview
with activist aidy barkin democratic
presidential hopeful joe biden gave his
full support to defunding the police
in the united police in the u.s ap's
assessment false
biden said he supports redirecting some
police funding to address mental health
or to change the prison system
i'm sorry what did the brookings
institute say so who's right
this is why no one has any idea what's
really happening i have an answer i have
an answer yeah
trump is exactly trump is right he is
he was correct yep so so this is the
problem when trump says hillary clinton
acid washed her
her server and then nbc says hillary
clinton
actually didn't use a corrosive
substance on her computer that would be
ridiculous
or then when trump's having a candid
interview with chris wallace
he doesn't have these sources pulled up
in front of him i'll tell you what
donald trump
i i i'm going to assume you're listening
because you better be of course
or trump jr kaylee mckenna needs to be
standing next to you for all of these
interviews
100 you know why because she got that
binder with all those tabs
and chris wallace would be like no sir
joe biden does not want to
up up up up kaylee and she go i have it
right here actually he said we would yes
absolutely
when asked if we would reallocate and
then chris wallace will go well
re-allocating is that
kaylee and then she'd go yes actually
right here and this source this source
this horse and this source they all
defined defunding as reallocating funds
so yes joe biden agrees with that and
then it would be over yep
he knew kaylee mckenna you got she's got
you got to bring her you just have her
she she's the press secretary yeah she
should be just standing right off
then when trump wants to call his aides
over and they read through the the biden
bernie pact
and they don't know what's in it or
where joe biden said he wants to
reallocate some of this funding
i'm pretty sure kelly mckenney has all
the answers yep she does
she is that she's a beast that photo you
saw that you've seen that photo i wonder
if people remind her yeah her binders
got all these tabs of like all these
different stories
and i love it she'll get asked at some
stupid question and she'll go
i'm glad you asked and then she'll pull
the tab and she'll go ah here we are
it's amazing oh yeah that example well
what about this example this example
this example in this example
next is and now
yes ladies and gentlemen i would like to
i would like to slam dunk the last
portion of this segment
oh slam it babe does joe biden want to
defund the police
well as we've broken down for you the
answer is a technical yes it
i mean he said he wants to relocate
funding that's the that's at least
one of the basic definitions so i think
we can say although there are many
people at different perspectives
he at least fits one of them but how
about this biden campaign staffer mocked
cops as worse than pigs and called for
defunding the police
[Laughter]
i understand it's not biden directly but
come on man
this it's biden's it's it's a campaign
staffer so maybe he doesn't know her but
this is a
part of his his his campaign same as
bernie sanders when he had those people
exposed by veritas okay
this is what this person sarah pearl
tweeted this it's a
it's an image it says please stop
calling cops pigs
pigs are highly intelligent and
empathetic animals who would never
racially profile you
and then there's hearts next to a pig
face i wonder if she's vegan
i bet she eats bacon i don't know maybe
i wouldn't be surprised if they're all
vegans
after what they were demanding from the
chaz we demand seitan
and uh no that was important then i
think there that that that was
the original pre-chaz chat jazz we
demand vegan food
i told you about i told you portland i
told you
the sad story of the the wasted vegan
pizza at occupy yeah you told me about
it yeah just this tastes weird someone's
trying to poison it well it looked weird
oh and nobody knew what it was yeah so
at occupy
a bunch of pizzas got delivered and
people opened it noticed that
on one pizza looked normal and the other
one the cheese looked like it wasn't
always
all the way melted right exactly and so
people were like uh i don't know this
looks weird
and someone tried it's like it doesn't
taste like regular pizza and they're
like
we don't we better not eat it and they
just dumped it such a shame
yeah it was vegan pizza yup and the
regular pizza was fine
the vegan pizza was probably way
healthier probably but so anyway
no doubt actually i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna pretend like just because
one campaign staffer called for
defunding the police or whatever
but i think you add this with what we
just talked about
and there it is joe biden his campaign
they do agree with the same activist
sentiment
call it whatever you want reallocate you
know uh
re uh you know address whatever
joe biden says yes absolutely when the
activists
ask him if he's on board yeah defund
means take funds away
period so now it doesn't matter where
they go if you're moving them somewhere
else
you're defunding the police but now for
the sad pessimistic view of the world
oh great every single story
is this obviously not literally all
i'm just saying like 90 something
percent every day i'm going through the
news
and it's like you know snopes did donald
trump
actually you know like did donald trump
carry a bag of burning puppies
you know and toss them into a burning
building mostly true
and then what it'll say is while donald
trump
did throw a bag of puppies into a
burning building
it was actually because he was moving
them out of the burning room into the
safe room where the firefighters were
waiting to safely rescue them it was the
living room of the building
that's what they do right yeah so it's
like you get this really great story
donald trump you know jumps in front of
car to save little kid and they'll show
the picture of trump
like this in front of the kid in front
of the car and it'll be like
you know did trump push a kid in front
of a car true
donald trump pushed to the kid who was
in front of a car to save his life right
it's like that's not the context
yeah man learn the context people no
it's on purpose learn the content they
know
jim acosta knows what he's doing the
media are storytellers
that's what i'm finding out they're
storytellers that tell the story
that they want to tell and you have to
look it up look up the context that's
what i've been doing everyone's keeps
giving me oh well here's this article
and i'm like all right i'll read it yeah
but dude
and then i'll go and follow the sources
to the the end
to where it actually is talking about
and i'm like oh so it's not true and i
go back to the conversation
okay so that's not true but what the
right thing is yes it is
someone actually said that to me but the
average person spends most of their day
at work
you're right and if you're all these
people coming at me on facebook
that's what they tend to do also they
don't
i and i actually try to explain to them
okay well my job
is actually researching all of this
non-stop all day that's what i've been
doing
even even my free time i don't even have
free time anymore my free time is when
we go skating
yeah as soon as that's over i'm like all
right back to the grind
you know it's like but they don't want
to hear that they don't want to hear it
they're like are you a doctor adam are
you a doctor
someone told me that today uh because
i've been i've been
talking about certain things on facebook
and and
basically what they like to do is how
about you
you know just leave it to the experts
adam and then when you say something
like actually it's my job to read the
news all day and fact check these things
gone they just don't respond that's true
because they don't actually care about
what's important what's true
this is a serious cultural problem we
have because i'll tell you what man if
the american people don't want
to high-five and yell america together
well then that's that's a bigger problem
that's that's all that matters
so look even if even if we disagreed on
you know certain policy issues as long
as we agree on america
you know that's not even the thing
anymore people are we don't agree we're
starting to
be convinced that america is not good
and it's like
that's crazy to me that is insane and i
know a lot of these people have never
been outside america
and they need to not even outside their
hometown i i i know for a fact that they
have
so but as far as leaving the states i
know one friend of mine has traveled
around a lot and he should know better
but it's like i read america is an
amazing place
we are we are free here the our civil
rights
how many how many countries have have
the amount of civil rights that we do
what do you think
oh man i honestly don't know what
percentage we're really small actually
tiny percentage because well it's it's
it's really really small even european
countries
don't have the same civil rights you're
absolutely right like canada you can get
arrested for saying naughty words on the
internet
in the in the uk count dankula made made
it
count dankula's story is the perfect
example of how insane things are even in
western nations because he made a joke
for like
10 subscribers of his dog doing
something offensive
yeah they arrested the guy and they like
they took the money out of his bank they
charged and convicted him
for making a joke on the internet in the
united states this even happens to
people you know you know there are
stories
people uh posting rap lyrics getting
arrested and charged with terror and
stuff
seriously yeah there's one story about
some kid who posted rap lyrics
and the rap lyrics were lewd no like
terroristic oh wow yeah like talking
about
you know popping a cap or whatever
that's a whole nother conversation about
about a certain culture that's uh
you know making people do certain things
and believe that that's the cool thing
to do
it's not even about that it's about the
fact that we have a first amendment
right here in this country yeah
and even when the line is blurred you
can sometimes have your rights violated
and we still are one of the best
countries you're right
i don't i don't i guess arguably in
terms of freedom
mexico might be better you know why why
they've got
you know i think it's in like southern
mexico a bunch of anarchists okay like
both left and right wing
can i just do whatever they want because
it's it's relatively lawless
yeah uh luke rudkowski if we are changed
went down to
i i guess i don't know if it's acapulco
and narcopolco or however
like wherever it is but he literally
went to the city that's all
private it's like private security ever
there's like no real
strong government people do whatever
they want yeah and then rich people like
to go down there
and have private security guards
guarding their property because they can
do whatever they want yeah
like think like think about the things
you can't actually do like maybe maybe
play a game a poker with your friends
you know maybe uh fire a bow and arrow
in your backyard
like i i want to talk about things that
like if you knew what you were doing
and you had a decent-sized backyard and
you had the proper safety and all that
stuff and you knew it was safe
you still can't do that in a lot of
places like
they'll call the cops or even a bb gun
so a lot of people thinking about that
and
probably drugs they want to go off in
the middle of nowhere
but these places like in southern mexico
are not necessarily the middle of
nowhere they're towns with functioning
you know stores and goods and
it's interesting man talk about freedom
but you know what
i do personally think i am not i'm not
personally not an anarchist
i do like some government you know i'm
i'm i would consider myself liberal so
a little bit more government than a
libertarian would want yeah that means
i like the cops i like being able to to
have a justice system that for the most
part tries to get it right not perfect
not all the time
better than some random dude you know
because uh in this in an archipelago
some lefty hippies were actually doing
drugs something and somebody ran in and
just shot him and killed two of the guys
yeah just went bang bang bang and what
do you do you can't do anything about it
and so i see that stuff and i'm like
that's why i like police
not because the cops are going to
magically appear and stop this
you got to defend yourself you get
responsibilities true but that we have a
justice system
that will to whatever degree you're
happy with like not sometimes it's not
perfect they'll try to stop these people
so they don't do it again
yeah and that does reduce the amount of
crimes and murder
and now the best part man new york city
they defunded the police one billion
dollars they
re reassigned 600 anti-crime unit cops
crimes skyrocketed and now guess what
they're asking for it back
local actors please please bring back
our police
we didn't local activists in new york
are saying like no we want our cops back
yep the crime's going up help right and
what is what do we get from aoc what is
surprise
aoc is like well it'll be like the
suburbs they just want brexit really
that's what it well before she even got
to that statement
well what does defunding the police look
like oh it looks like the suburbs
where everyone has like a a big large
property and they're a nice house like
really that's what it's going to look
like
sure less dense population less dense
population
people aren't living on top of each
other hmm that's what it's going to look
like to you
what's she where does she live she comes
she is mary antoinette it's true
she comes out and says defund the police
means defund and this isn't enough we
need more
yeah meanwhile the people who actually
live in new york are saying please help
us
we need we need our police and is she
listening no
she's saying maybe they need bread i
love that dude that's mary antoinette it
is
let them have bread let them have bread
maybe they're stealing bread
while they're shooting each other and
wow man and beating cops up
yeah yeah and shooting each other new
york in front of
their kids you know it's funny we talked
about donald trump
setting up these luxury buildings to get
rich people to come back to pay taxes
yep
now trump's gone everybody you know all
these people all these people in new
york are ragging on them all the time
and now their tax base is eroding due to
their
horrifying job dealing with kovid yep
they blame him for it but it's all
cuomo's fault
yeah absolutely it's all de blasio's
fault to be fair and and there's mostly
both to blame yeah i think bill de
blasio first
yeah and then cuomo but both of them
they probably they were probably talking
about it
it's like they're both standing there
yelling we saved the city and like
everybody's dead from covid patrick and
spongebob yeah exactly
yeah we did it we saved the city
congratulations
it ran him up killed a bunch of people
and that was them
you know there's like bill de blasio's
people early on saying
come down to chinatown nancy pelosi was
doing the same thing yeah and they want
to try and blame trump for it look man
you can
you you can criticize trump who's not
good doing good enough but you have to
do better than him
like if you're doing a really bad job
yeah like imagine this
imagine like the kitchen
is a disaster zone and like you're
cleaning it and i'm sitting there
literally throwing garbage on the floor
and i'm like
adam why don't you clean up your mess
and you're like first of all i didn't
make the mess second of all you're
literally throwing garbage on the floor
like
you can't be by the way this this
actually happens
no this doesn't happen no i'm just
kidding but my point is
you can criticize trump for sure and you
can you but but
like i think it's fair to say if you've
got criticism you've gotta you've got
can you do better right one of the
problems i have with uh actually you
know what i'll do
i'm gonna give you shout outs to a casey
neistat video
and try and connect these into a similar
idea about relativity
so they're saying trump's doing a bad
job relative to what
who do we compare kovid to right other
countries that are smaller and have
different you know
border controls you know when you look
at these european nations that are much
more than the us and they were able to
lock down their borders right that
certainly helped we didn't lock down our
borders between states up to the states
to do not trump and remember we are
called the united states
for a reason there's different states
every state has its own
laws it has its own governors they do
their own thing they straight up told
trump
to f off like don't even don't even try
to tell us what to do
we're running the show we're the
governors he was like here's my
guidelines yeah
yeah he tried to help and they were like
no no those are your guidelines this is
the united states this is what we do but
then as soon as
as soon as that corner turns they flip
it on him like whoa whoa now we can
blame him now we're gonna now we're
gonna switch it around
it's relativity relative is trump doing
a bad job on covid
in order to say yes or no you need a
control
united states which does not exist
that's a good point you and and so i see
a lot of people saying
well look at italy how come they well
italy is like one state
okay well still how come italy versus
versus what new york because that's real
new york is the epicenter
right well what about pennsylvania do we
have border restrictions stopping people
from traveling between new york and
pennsylvania
no you can just go boop boop and trump
can't do anything about that
yeah so it's not the same it's very hard
to quantify
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
itunes and spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you